i think a lot of people also have been
sick for so long that they don't
understand what it feels like to be
healthy i absolutely agree it's it's
human nature to get used to where we're
at yeah right and i and so you see this
on both sides of the coin when
somebody's miserable every day i didn't
realize how good i could feel without
pain and rosacea and severe heartburn
and and dunlap do you know what dunlap
is michaela here in the south it sounds
horrifying it is it's when your belly is
done lapped over your belt that's a
southernism that we say here and that
means you're fat
i didn't i didn't realize how miserable
i was until i corrected all those things
[Music]
welcome to episode 117 of the michaela
peterson podcast featuring the one and
only dr ken berry dr barry is a doctor
who specializes in the carnivore diet
and keto diets he's incredibly
knowledgeable one of the most
knowledgeable doctors in this area that
exists out there
and his last name is barry so that's
funny
we talk about lies we've been told about
health and how to transition to a
healthy lifestyle this guy's the
best-selling author of lies my doctor
told me
and i support what he does
i'm also slowly convincing him to try
the lion diet
if you want to learn about how to get
healthier in a way that actually works
check this episode out if you enjoy it
please hit subscribe
[Music]
dr ken berry welcome to my podcast hey
michaela thank you so much
i feel like the last time we spoke i did
a live on your facebook or something
like that
yeah i think we didn't live maybe on
youtube and facebook and
that's been a minute though it's about
time for us to converse again
yes so before we get started for anyone
who doesn't know you can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do sure i'm dr ken berry
i'm a family physician classically
trained in allopathic medicine
uh i've been been in active practice for
about 21 years now
and uh i have a youtube channel
that i'm trying to grow i've got
facebook twitter instagram all the
things i'm even on tick tocker you won't
take talk michaela
you should be i am on tick tock how do
you feel about tick tock i'll go check
out your tick tock but the reason i'm on
all those social media platforms is
because i have to go to where the people
are to help them understand
the lessons that i learned in my own
journey first of all towards severe
chronic illness and then
doing a 180 away from that back to
what i would consider
fairly close to optimal health as a 52
year old and so
the things i learned along that
journey
and the things that i saw reflected in
my patients when they changed their diet
that's kind of compelled me
some would say called me to to kind of
focus all my effort on reaching out to
the the millions of people who suffer
from chronic disease chronic
inflammation
obesity type 2 diabetes fatty liver
you know
autoimmune conditions that all of these
things are at least to some degree
reversible by eating a proper human diet
and so it really i'm on fire for that
and have been for the last three or four
years and i don't see any plans in the
future to stop doing that because it's
you know i'm a doctor i'm supposed to
make people better
i'm not supposed to medicate them i'm
not supposed to tell them there's no
hope i'm supposed to give them hope and
then also give them a path that they can
follow and and also introduce them to a
tribe of other people who have had
similar problems and similar journeys
and say hey we all we all got better and
you can too
that is what i like to hear from a
doctor
what else would a doctor say
i know i know i know they say a lot of
times
they say
yeah they say
you're chronically ill and there's
nothing you can do about it and hear
some pills yeah you're just unlucky
that's great yeah exactly and i i think
that even if a patient is screwed i
think there's always hope for at least
some degree of improvement and that's
the that's the thing that we need to
focus on
not the fact you know if the odds are
bad why focus on that because you're not
in any way helping the patient every
interaction between a patient and a
doctor or
in between a youtuber and a watcher
should be therapeutic it should be
uh an opportunity to instill some hope
however small to hope there should
always be hope involved and there should
always be a path this work for me this
has worked for thousands or tens of
thousands of people
you should try this
so what happened to you you said you had
chronic health issues yeah so as a young
teenager and a young man i was very
slender very seemingly very healthy
i just ate a complete junk food diet i
was you know going through medical
school and residency i didn't have time
definitely to cook but really didn't
have time to to
think about food at that point
and my body had not given me enough
negative feedback yet that i knew that
that was important and but when i got
out of residency started my very active
practice i was working in the emergency
department
two to four nights a week and so i might
get an hour or two
and then also running a full-time monday
through friday family practice
i quickly started to gain weight get
inflamed
miserable joint pain
i i became at my worst morbidly obese i
was just over the the criteria for being
diagnosed as morbidly obese i was
pre-diabetic i had severe gerd heartburn
i had rosacea chronic joint pain and was
just getting fat
and miserable and uh you might be able
to tell from what little accent i do
have that i'm from the south and the
people in the south i grew up around
were very common sense people
you couldn't be a mechanic and be
successful if your car wouldn't start
people judge you on that here you
couldn't be a hairdresser and be
successful if your hair was ratchet
right you had to have you had to have
nice hair to be a successful hairdresser
and in the same respect you couldn't be
a fat miserable sick doctor
people would be like okay doctor you you
told me i need to lose weight and their
eyes would would for one second go down
and look at my belly where the button
over my um um umbilicus was in danger of
popping at any second
they would judge me and i felt that
judgment and i think that was
therapeutic judgment because it
cast a light on me
dude you're not you're not being
consistent you're being very
inconsistent you're fat and pre-diabetic
but you're going to tell this person
what's wrong with them and so i could
not tolerate the incongruity of that i
had to fix that and so
i started out with with primal paleo
type diets they maybe helped a little
in the process of doing that i
discovered this thing called the
ketogenic diet
and so i thought well i'll try that for
a few months and that immediately
started the weight loss
my hemoglobin a1c which is the primary
marker used for type 2 diabetes that
doctors look at it started to come down
precipitously
all of my symptoms of heartburn joint
pain inflammation rosacea dandruff skin
tags all of that stuff started to get
better
on this ketogenic diet and in the
process i was i was reading about uh
your your dad jordan peterson he's he's
you know doing this carnivore diet and
i'm like that's interesting because
that's as low carb as you can possibly
get right and then i saw this crazy dr
sean baker an orthopedic surgeon he's
doing this carnivore diet
and so on my facebook page i just i just
issued a challenge i said hey guys let's
do 30 days of this carnivore diet let's
see what happens and so
when i tell you i had heartburn it was
severe almost disabling it was so severe
i had to take two nexium
which is a very strong prescription
medication for
um
gerd i had to take two a day so when the
drug rep came to drop off the nexium
samples
the patients didn't get those i got all
those those were mine because i needed
two a day and so i would have to do that
plus some tons of rollage or some other
antacid uh during the day it affected my
ability to speak it affected my ability
to to breathe and and swallow at the
same time it was really it was really
bad
so on a ketogenic diet full of real
whole one ingredient foods not all the
keto shakes and cakes and cookies and
pies but real keto food
my heartburn which was severe 10 out of
10
got 80 percent better and i'm like
huh at that point i didn't know enough i
hadn't reached out to enough people to
know that that wasn't just an anecdotal
weird thing that happened to me that's
something that very commonly happens for
people
with severe reflux when they start a
ketogenic diet but then when i did my
one month carnivore challenge
at the end of that month i realized i
hadn't taken a single thing for
heartburn that entire month
uh which was very unusual for me
and so i thought you know that's really
cool but also very weird i'm gonna i'm
gonna do this carnivore another month so
i'll let everybody on my facebook page
off the hook they could go back to their
keto if they wanted to but i stuck with
carnivore
and have been a carnivore now for 28 29
months
and at this point i have no intentions
of ever going back
occasionally i'll cheat on carnivore
with keto for an anniversary or a
birthday or some family get together but
on a daily basis consistently
i eat and all
it's an animal based diet for me and and
that i i have not had any heartburn in
29 months which is if anybody listen
this suffered from severe heartburn
severe gerd reflux
that's miraculous to say i have not had
a single symptom in 29 months
wow
i am very glad to hear that me too
yeah that's fantastic
i've been i've been doing it since
december 2017
and
i've tried a couple times i'm okay for
before before we get into that what does
your diet look like specifically what's
animal based look like for you what's
like a daily
daily meals what does that look like so
it's there's always a large serving of
some meat
routinely i can i can eat eggs just fine
some people on carnivore depending on
why they're doing it may or may not be
able to include eggs i found that many
people
who think they're allergic to eggs it's
actually the egg whites if they'll just
stick to the yolk they they don't have
any inflammatory symptoms at all and so
for
i typically don't break my fast until
one or two or three pm every day i'm
just not hungry i don't think about it
i've got stuff to do
i've got lots of farm chores outside
i've got you know the
people to reach people to help and so
it's somewhere between one and four p.m
i'll be like oh i haven't eaten today
and so i'll go have maybe a a 12 ounce
ribeye
with um
seven or eight egg yolk scrambled and
that that'll be my breakfast for that
day
i can include some dairy
always full fat real good quality dairy
if i get too far off into the dairy i'll
start to notice some inflammation
in different parts of my body so a tiny
bit of cheese a tiny bit of heavy cream
but the vast majority of my diet is uh
is is meat and eggs
i i notice i do better on ruminant meat
so
beef goat sheep
uh venison is fine
even elk is fine all the it seems that
all the ruminant meat so it has some
magical quality for me i just feel
better i'm more mentally clear
when i eat ruminant meat i can tolerate
some chicken and some pork
but if i if i eat too much of that i
just don't feel my best and i don't
necessarily think
that chicken and pork are bad i just
think for me personally they're less
good
i react terribly to pork
like terribly to pork i can eat a lot of
the plants easier than than pork that
gives me really bad autoimmune symptoms
yeah and i think weirdly
and i think everyone should experiment
with their diet because you you've
discovered that about yourself and and
it is true that we're all at to some
degree
uh
biogenetically unique and different
uh i think the gut microbiome which we
don't know nearly enough about i think
that also plays a role
probably your your ancestral heritage
your dna place some degree of a role i
don't think we know
one of those to talk about them with
confidence but
it's great that you know that that now
you know i might i can have a bite of
bacon but if i get crazy on the bacon
i'm going to suffer whereas i i can eat
six pieces of bacon and and eggs and
it's no big deal for me
but i think that that that is important
for people to understand that there is
some diversity between us although we
are all 99.9 percent the same
genetically
yeah well if everybody was as sensitive
as my dad and i then there'd be
we'd be like the population would look a
little different yeah
okay
so i think we should address some like
common concerns for people if they're
not familiar with the carnivore diet
although if they've been watching my
channel they probably are but for people
who say suffer from kidney disease or
heart disease
or high cholesterol do those people have
to be worried switching on to something
that's animal based no
next question no let me go into that a
little bit so no you don't and so
there's a huge myth in the medical
community which should not be
susceptible to mythology they should
focus and and act only on facts only on
evidence but there's this huge
misconception in the medical community
that a diet
high in protein is bad for your kidneys
and i've actually done several youtube
videos about this explaining that this
is a complete nutri myth
there's no research definitely no
controlled research that shows that a
high protein diet protein from any
source
is bad for the human kidneys and there's
definitely no
control research showing that protein
from meat is in any way bad for kidneys
and so
i've started using the the phrase meat
is good for your kidneys prove me wrong
show me the research and until i've yet
to have a single
controlled research studies thrown in my
face saying you're wrong big guy
meat is bad for your kidneys there is no
research that shows that yet the average
medical doctor dietitian nutritionist
they will especially someone with stage
one two or three chronic kidney disease
they will scare them to death oh you
need to avoid especially red meat
somehow red meat's magical
it's much much worse for your kidneys
than than you know white meat
but they're okay that's great so where's
the research oh then you hear the
crickets chirping because there is no
research that supports that whatsoever
which makes that
at best a hypothesis at worst a myth or
a big fat lie like i talk about in my
book
uh people with any medical condition
you're still a human being you're still
homo sapien sapien therefore you need to
eat a human specific diet a proper human
diet and for every human on the planet a
proper human diet consists of a large
percentage
of fatty meat and you ju
until we've got some controlled research
you can't even argue otherwise
what about heart disease yeah so heart
you know red meat is going to cause a
heart attack uh eating red meat is going
to raise your cholesterol so the
american heart association which is the
de facto world heart association because
most other countries take their walking
orders directly
from the american heart association when
it comes to all matters heart related
they have stopped recommending
a maximum amount of cholesterol intake
in the diets the research is very clear
and the reason why you didn't know that
michaela is because they they didn't
have a press conference as they should
have
they should have held a press conference
and said we know we know we've been
recommending that you limit your
cholesterol intake
for decades but the research doesn't
support that and it doesn't matter at
all how much cholesterol you eat your
body's going to make the amount of
cholesterol you need so we are no longer
recommending that that's that would have
been the uh ethical thing for them to do
because what happens when they don't
hold that press conference is we even
though the top cardiologists and the
people that set the guidelines they've
stopped worrying about cholesterol
intake in your diet
and they've stopped uh recommending that
to their personal patients but we have
this thing that i call the echo of the
lie
that i talk about in the book so even
though the preeminent authorities have
stopped talking about that they don't
even it's not even in the if you print
out their dietary guidelines it's not in
there anymore
but we still have all these doctors and
dietitians and nutritionists and mothers
and fathers who are saying oh don't eat
cholesterol it's bad for your heart
that's it and it's idiotic
because it was a it was a weak
hypothesis for a few decades and it's
been completely disproven even though
the researchers were trying desperately
to prove that it was a valid hypothesis
they failed miserably
and we've still got this echo of the
light that your hairdresser will tell
you that your aunt betty will tell you
oh don't eat those the egg yolks it's
too high in cholesterol
but there's no research to support that
so
a lot of people listen to this will be
like you're telling me the american
heart association said that cholesterol
is no longer a molecule of concern when
it comes to dietary intake
yep it's on page 187 of their guidelines
buried in the minutia but it's there
and so then well okay well then what
about saturated fat eating saturated
fats bad things yeah well they've also
stepped very quietly away from that
recommendation as well
they don't really speak about oh if you
eat too much saturated fat that is a
direct directly causative of heart
disease no actually that's no longer in
their guidelines either but again they
didn't hold that that press conference
to let the world know
so we've got all these people
who mean well right they mean very well
but they're just wrong
and uh you and
any smart person understands that no
matter how good your intentions are if
the information and teaching that you're
giving is just wrong you're gonna do
harm and so there's all these people who
are scared to death of ancestrally
appropriate foods like egg yolks and
fatty meat because they're afraid it
will affect their heart because of the
cholesterol or the saturated fat
and the world authority on all things
heart related has stopped that
recommendation they don't even recommend
that you limit cholesterol intake or
limit saturated fat intake any longer
but they didn't have a press conference
so no one knows
what's that saying uh the road to hell
is paved with good intentions yeah in
this case i think that's very applicable
yeah no that's completely criminal in my
opinion i agree
at what point do we have a young
attorney out there who's hungry for a
class action lawsuit or do we have an
assistant d.a in some state who's hungry
to make a name for herself and who files
a class-action lawsuit against one of
these organizations saying hey you're
actually doing harm
yeah by by not making public the fact
that you no longer recommend that people
limit cholesterol and and saturated fat
intake because here's the harm that's
being done
there are all kinds of vitamins and
minerals essential fatty acids that you
really can only get from foods that are
high in cholesterol
and high in saturated fat and so if
you're avoiding cholesterol and
saturated fat you're not getting access
to this this this cornucopia of vitamins
and minerals and fatty acids that your
body absolutely needs
for essential optimal human function you
might be able to limp along without
these vitamins and minerals and fatty
acids but never will you realize your
best health your most optimal function
it's just not accessible to you because
you're being restricted from these
necessary nutrients
yeah i think a lot of people also have
been sick for so long that they don't
understand what it feels like to be
healthy i absolutely agree it's it's
human nature to get used to where we're
at yeah right and i and so you see this
on both sides of the coin when
somebody's miserable every day
i didn't realize how good i could feel
without pain and rosacea and severe
heartburn and and dunlap do you know
what dunlap is michaela here in the
south it sounds it's horrifying it is
it's when your belly is done lapped over
your belt that's a southernism that we
say here and that means you're fat
i didn't i didn't realize how miserable
i was until i corrected all those things
but then on the flip side people like
you and i now that we've found our point
on the spectrum of a proper human diet
and we feel great every single day we
kind of get used to that as well don't
we and so
it felt amazing at the beginning but
then after 29 months of this it just
feels normal to me now to feel great and
to be able to go out and work on the
farm and sweat two gallons out you know
just non-stop manual labor that just
feels normal to me and so i don't i
don't you lose sight of just how bad or
how good you feel i think that's just
human nature
i think it's human nature too however
have you tried just doing like lion diet
style for six weeks super strict i have
not and uh uh that is
to
i agree because
i feel great now but could i feel even
better exactly i know i totally get the
logic behind that and at some point i'll
i'll probably do three months because i
really feel like 90 days is what you
really need for any dietary experiment
to let your body have time to calm down
and to improve and at some point i will
do 90 days of just beef salt and water
and and just see
uh and you know i may have to include a
little lamb in that because lamb lamb i
eat mostly lamb very fond of lamb and i
like godot so i may just do 90 days of
rooming at me
yeah and i may do that here and i'll
i'll issue a you know a challenge to all
my people when the time comes
okay cool keep me posted i'll advertise
that on my instagram too so people can
join that's fun uh let's talk a little
bit about transition symptoms you've
seen from people going from say the
standard american diet into an
animal-based diet what people should be
prepared for yeah so there are a couple
of things that you need to
understand and also
be ready for so the first thing in my
opinion uh highly processed
carbohydrates are very very addictive
they mimic all of the signs of addiction
uh we we can see uh pet scan and and mri
data in the nucleus accumbens
you know which is basically the center
that of the brain that that leads to
addictive behavior
it lights up just like you're smoking
pot or smoking nicotine or smoking crack
it lights up the same way when you're
eating highly processed carbohydrates or
even thinking about eating them which is
interesting right and so the first thing
you're going to contend with is
carbohydrate withdrawal symptoms and a
lot of people call this the keto flu or
the carnivore flu but when people are
quitting smoking and they have these
same exact symptoms of withdrawal
nobody calls that the the the quitters
flu that right because you you know that
it's bad for you to smoke so you it
doesn't matter what your symptoms of
withdrawal are
it's still worth it in the long run to
quit smoking but but food is so wrapped
up in emotion in religion in family ties
that we don't think of that the same way
as we do tobacco which obviously no one
needs to smoke
no one needs to to do illicit drugs no
one needs to be an alcoholic so there's
we don't have all the social and
emotional ties to those things we can
just
single those out and say that is bad for
you stop that
but food's different right because we
have all these emotional strings
attached to it and so when you change
your diet from the standard american
crap processed diet to a ketogenic diet
or a carnivore diet and you start to
feel miserable
people immediately are going to jump to
the conclusion well duh that diet's bad
for you you should go back to eating
your regular diet instead of thinking oh
maybe you're having withdrawal symptoms
from the highly processed grains and the
sugar content maybe you need to give
that 3 to 14 days just like the
withdrawal from any other standard
addictive substance
for those
signs and symptoms of withdrawal to
abate
because that's exactly what you have to
do and some people they don't have much
withdrawal symptom and these are usually
people who are already eating paleo or
trying to eat real whole foods but if
you're if you're going straight from
carnivore
from a standard american or a standard
canadian crap diet
you're probably going to have three to
seven days of withdrawal symptoms and
it's going to suck that doesn't mean you
should stop that means you should
persevere until you get to the other
side
because that's where all the benefits
are the second thing that people need to
be aware of
is when you're eating a high
carbohydrate diet your insulin levels
are staying chronically high
your levels of chronic inappropriate
inflammation are chronically high that
both of those things are going to make
you store a lot of fluid unhealthy fluid
in your body
right
and so the way the human kidney works is
when you start eating a very low
carbohydrate diet your blood sugar
levels and your insulin levels are going
to quickly return to normal and that's
going to cause a diuresis which means
that you're going to start to to urinate
out all this unhealthy fluid that you've
been storing inappropriately all over
your body
but the way the human kidney works is
you can't just urinate out free water
you have to have some degree of salt go
with that water you have to have some
degree of magnesium and potassium and
even calcium has to go with that water
because of the way the human kidneys
designed and so you'll wind up with with
other symptoms of being not eating
enough salt because we all been taught
that salt is bad
which is another big fat lie that you
don't have to worry about when you start
eating a proper human diet
but for the first few days of this
transition you need to be very mindful
that you're eating enough salt and you
need to be very mindful that you're
getting enough magnesium and potassium
either in your diet or in the form of a
supplement and those things alone
mitigate this the side the symptoms of
of carbohydrate withdrawal and just the
the keto flu or the carnivore flu that
many people mislabel it as
it's just electrolyte fluctuations salt
fluctuations and carbohydrate withdrawal
that's what you're suffering from it's
short-lived it's temporary and i promise
you it is worth the three to seven days
transition period to get to the other
side
for me
and for people i've seen who have really
severe autoimmune disorders that can be
up to 21 days the cravings i had and i
and taken i went from a standard
american diet to a very restrictive
paleo diet to a keto diet with no dairy
and no eggs
to the carnivore diet over a period of
like two years
and the cravings
the cravings were bad enough and they
lasted three weeks for me where i was
having dreams about these foods yeah and
it was ridiculous every time i so i
didn't screw up because as soon as i cut
out of food it was like i'm
it's out
but occasionally i'd be somewhere and
i'd have some contamination on something
and as soon as i had that contaminated
food all my cravings would come back it
was wild and so it'd be like i'd have
something and there'd be soybean oil on
it and i wouldn't know and then i'd have
soy cravings yep it was crazy
and i think and the
the other thing that
caused your withdrawal your cravings to
last longer
is your gut microbiome and as i said
earlier we don't know nearly enough
about this but also you have a set of
fungi that live in your gut as well and
and people most people aren't aware of
that but you have a
microfungum as well as a microbiome
and fungi can have serious effects on
your mental health and so i i opine this
is merely a hypothesis because nobody's
studying this
but i think when you go from a high
carbohydrate diet to a very very low
carbohydrate diet
your gut bacteria rebel because you are
populated with a high carb loving
uh
bunch of bacteria in your gut and all of
a sudden they're not getting the sugar
they're not getting the high processed
grains and starches that they they
operate best on
and so they start to down regulate as
well as protest you can just imagine the
little bacteria with their placards
saying hell no no more meat right
but what you're also doing is up
regulating all of the healthy beneficial
bacteria and funguses that love
a low carbohydrate nutrient dense diet
and that can take a few weeks to to get
your gut
bacteria and fungus regulated and a lot
of carnivores notice they'll have three
days to three weeks of diarrhea
and that's part of their transition and
that's because that's that's the
protestation of your gut bacteria and
fungus saying what the hell are you
doing where's where are my carbs and and
i think also vegetable seed oils do play
a role in that as well and a lot of
people don't understand the power that
fungus can have over
your actual mental activity
if no one's seen the the video of the
zombie ants
where
a fungus literally makes this ant ignore
all of its its instinct in its training
climb to a top of the leaf attached to a
certain kind of leaf on a certain tree
on a certain side of the tree
and then die and then fall to the ground
so that the fungus can re replicate in
the ant's body just search youtube for
or fungus ants i'm gonna link that
crazy screwed up it is but that's the
power that that fungi can have over
seemingly sentient beings and make you
literally become a zombie and you're
going to the fridge and looking for the
carbs and it's completely against your
will
but yeah i think that's absolutely a
thing and i think that's something that
our researchers at the hobbit school of
public health they need to start looking
into that kind of stuff
yeah instead of oh every piece of bacon
you eat shortens your life by seven
minutes because they kind of played that
that's a that's a dead horse they need
to stop beating that and start looking
at the effect that the microbiome and
the fungus have on our behavior
and changing our mental health
when i first went to paleo that's when
the cravings were the worst and i could
tell i knew because i've been doing
research on microbiome even though
there's not a lot to read out there
that's
like legitimate exactly because it's so
new but i could tell that the cravings
weren't mine like i'd be like no i'm on
this diet and then just like angel food
cake would just appear in my head and
i'd be like
what is that what is that and i'd be
hungry but i wouldn't be hungry for the
food that was healthy i'd just be hungry
for the food that wasn't healthy and be
like well then i'm not hungry if like if
i only want to eat one food but i don't
want a steak that's not actual hunger so
i just got angry at it i was like how
dare you whatever's in me trying to
control me how dare you starve
and that was very unpleasant absolutely
okay so i have your book this is your
older book
right here
lies my doctor told me which is a great
book
but
what is what is happening with this new
book so i'm i'm working on my my new
book and it's tentatively titled the
proper human diet because i think that
there is a spectrum
that every single human on the planet if
if they
if their goal is to achieve optimal
health optimal function both physically
and mentally you need to be eating on
the proper human diet spectrum i'm going
to try to have it out by the new year
that may or may not happen i have a bit
of adhd and so i tend to get distracted
but i am working diligently on that i
have a team working with me to kind of
keep me focused
uh sometimes that's a challenge but i
think it's going to be a very important
book perhaps even more important than
lies uh when i wrote lies i i was called
to write that book i i could not sleep i
could not eat uh nisha basically
uh recounting the that the memories now
she's like yeah i basically didn't see
you for 18 months while you're writing
that book
and uh i i think that the proper human
diet is going to wind up being a more
important book that's going to be more
helpful to even more people than lies
was and i can't wait to get it finished
but
it's a work in progress
okay well i'm looking forward to that
this is a good one i mean i can tell why
you
felt like you were called to writing it
medical myths that can harm your health
there's probably an emotional aspect to
that yeah well it's so it's such a
convoluted complex
topic but because just think of the
interaction in the average doctor's
office here's a doctor who got received
very little training on nutrition right
on average in western medicine it's
maybe a few hours of training
and and then you they are looked upon by
the patient as a an authority figure
almost like a witch doctor like they
know things i don't know
anything that comes out of their mouth i
should consider gospel i should do what
they say but the doctor not only doesn't
know what the hell he or she is talking
about when it comes to human nutrition
on average
they don't know that they don't know
yeah and then they trust these
preeminent authorities like the american
diabetes association the american heart
association the american academy of
pediatrics they trust these people just
like the patient trusts them so you've
got this almost exponential
just
terrible
trust problem and it multiplies each
step up the ladder you go so not only is
the doctor diluted misled
then you multiply that by the doctor
misleading and diluting the patient
so it just becomes almost an uh an
unsolvable puzzle of how do you fix that
interaction
but that that's the most important
interaction between the doctor and the
patient and that's why i wrote lies like
i did
so that we break it up into one topic
and this is what your doctor says but
this is the actual truth of the matter
and i think that i wrote it for patients
but if you notice there's actually an
entire chapter in the back dedicated to
health care providers like this is
this is what you're doing wrong this is
how you correct that
and that's why i've dedicated the
remainder of my life to educating people
i'm not trying to change doctor's minds
or health care providers i don't give a
damn with the ada or the aha thinks of
me i could care less
i'm trying to reach out directly to
people and say hey i know your doctor
told you this but it's actually wrong
try this instead
and i've got pretty good feedback from
you know a few people so i think that
that model working very well
but it's really sad that that
interaction has to go so wrong and has
to just be just exponentially wrong
because no one in that interaction
neither the doctor nor the patient know
the truth
and they also don't know the power of
the truth i mean just for you and your
dad you know absolutely
all of these medical interventions all
of these prescription medications
became moot when you discovered the
power
of proper nutrition
species specific nutrition a proper
human diet when you became aware of that
yourself how many doctors did you did
you render meaningless in your life
when you made that adjustment and said
hey maybe my diet's way more important
than everybody thinks it is it's not
just about weight loss it's about
optimizing my health how many doctors
did you turn out to pasture personally
when you discovered oh my god diet
really matters a lot
a lot i had a lot of doctors i had a lot
of doctors i had a rheumatologist at a
psychiatrist i had a family doctor
that was that was three at least oh and
then i was going to see an immunologist
for allergies so that's four
oh and a dermatologist for skin so
that's five
i bet you there was more but there were
definitely five yeah so all of those
very complex interactions that you were
having with each different doctor
and then the prescription that
inevitably came from each different
doctor which added up for you as a
handful of pills every day multiple
times a day
how powerful is that that you basically
at some point just put up your hand and
said no no more no more i'm gonna do
something different i'm gonna try a
different path and then all of a sudden
all of these things all these doctors
all these pills which to you at the time
seemed mandatory
yeah life-saving if i'm going to have
any kind of a life i've got to see these
doctors i've got to take all these pills
just they just magically melt away in
importance and i think i've seen that's
replicated so many times in people on a
ketogenic diet or carnivore diet it's
like yeah i'm off five pills i'm off 10
pills i'm off three pills
i used to have four doctors now i have
one that i see once a year and that's
mainly just because i like hanging out
with my doctor once a year i don't
really need him or her anymore but
that that is such an empowering thing
that moment when you hold up your hand
say no more i'm going to try a different
path
it's scary initially very scary but
right before you make the decision and
then right after the decision
it can be terrifying like oh my god i'm
going to die i'm eating all this
saturated fat and cholesterol now
but then when the benefits start to come
some come quickly some take several
months before you start to realize them
it's at that point you know no i made
the right decision and i i'm i'm not
anti-doctor i'm not anti-medical
uh care i'm just anti-unnecessary
doctoring unnecessary pharmaceuticals
that's that's that's the anti that i am
if you want to put a label on me
and i think many people in the keto and
carnivore communities are now very
anti-medical intervention unless it's
absolutely necessary
yes
i agree
do you have words of comfort for people
who are
overweight or obese who are concerned
about increasing their meat intake and
losing weight
yeah so
carbohydrates are uniquely fattening for
human beings
in in my research that i've been doing
into not only human nutrition and human
medicine but also
archaeology
anthropology and even paleoanthropology
it's become quite obvious to me that
human beings are by design or by
evolution
low carbohydrate mammals
that's just what we are and so anyone
who's eating over a hundred total grams
of carbohydrates a day you're going to
have some degree of hyperinsulinemia
some degree of inappropriate chronic
inflammation and it may manifest in your
skin
it may manifest in your gut in your
joints in your hair
there are any number in your mental
health right we all tend to express the
inappropriate inflammation in
hyperinsulinemia
different parts of our body and that's
why initially a lot of people don't see
the connection between all of these
chronic medical conditions
and diets because we manifest them in
different ways
but once you start to lower the
carbohydrate intake you're going to
immediately start to notice
improvements and a lot of people lose
inches before they lose pounds or
kilograms and so i always recommend
people take your measurements when you
when you start keto when you start
carnivore because the scale may not move
for weeks or even months but you're
going to steadily be losing inches as
the inflammation and the unhealthy water
you lose that and as you start to burn
fat because it's been my experience that
when you start a
a fatty meat heavy keto diet or a
carnivore diet you're going to naturally
start to put on
muscle
and i've heard this from thousands of
people feedback
it's like i'm not working out at all but
but i'm noticing more muscle definition
is that normal and at first i thought
that was completely anecdotal and crazy
but after you hear something from a
thousand or two thousand or five
thousand people you have to give some
respect and credence
to all those anecdotal experiences right
also you're you're eating a diet that's
full of all the ingredients to build
muscle and to build stronger bones
and people don't realize when they say i
want to lose weight what they mean is i
want to lose fat
that's what you mean by that you don't
want to lose bone density you want to
lose muscle you don't want to lose
cartilage ligament
fascia and so you start to actually
build up all those vital organs your
bones get stronger your muscles get
stronger your your fascia which is which
is its own organ in the human body
starts to get tougher and stronger
ligaments tendons cartilage all this
stuff starts to get stronger that's
going to show up on the scale so as
you're losing stored fat you're actually
gaining these other things and so for
weeks you can actually break even on the
on the bathroom scale
and think this diet's not working for me
at all but if you're taking your
measurements
you unlock that information you're like
oh my god yeah i've lost three inches
off my waist even though the scale
hasn't moved
and so it can be
for some people the the benefits and the
weight loss is immediate for other
people it takes longer and so i i would
i would say you're now eating a proper
human diet how can that not be good for
you
at least in the long term if not in the
short term so stick with it and this
diet works equally well for people who
are underweight
and and a lot of people are surprised
when i say keto and carnivore are not
weight loss diets that's not what they
are
when i first started this seven eight
years ago i 100 believe that that keto
was a was a a temporary weight loss hack
because that's all i knew at that time
but now seeing this in totality i
realized no if you're underweight if you
suffer from an eating disorder or or
anything
you can actually gain weight but you're
not going to gain fat you're going to
gain muscle you're going to gain bone
density you're going to gain all the the
beneficial organs are going to actually
fill out and resume their normal
appearance
and i've seen people gain 20 30 40
pounds of needed weight
on both a ketogenic and a carnivore diet
yeah it seems to just normalize your
weight exactly right but it moves your
body weight to a proper weight for you
because it is a proper human diet that's
what it should do right
that is what it should do so if anyone
isn't aware
what how do you define a keto diet so a
keto diet for me
is definitely going to be under 50 total
grams of carbohydrates a day
for most people especially if you have
two lots of stored fat that you need to
burn off and lose it probably needs to
be under 20 total grams of carbohydrates
a day and i think that
total carbs that's a big deal because
as you know keto is becoming very very
popular and a lot of the big food
manufacturers are jumping into the keto
space
and if you let them count net carbs
they can trick you with with soluble
fibers and by misnaming things and a
friend of mine did an experiment she was
eating under 20 net grams of carbs a day
and she was eating over a hundred grams
of total carbs a day but still getting
less than 20 net and so the
why
so how is that different what's the
difference between net in total so total
carbs means counting every carb
including fiber because many of the
fibers some fibers are insoluble and you
truly don't absorb them and get any
carbohydrates from them at all
many fibers are soluble fibers and you
will at least partially digest those
with your goods and so um
tapioca fiber uh oat fiber corn fiber a
lot of these fibers are soluble fibers
but most people don't know the
difference right the average customer
and so they just see fiber and they
think boom fiber that's good i've heard
my doctor told me that i need fiber so
there you go
but
a lot of it so corn fiber and tapioca
fiber and oat fiber you're going to get
about two grams of carbs from each from
each gram uh you're going to get
desserts you see what i'm saying you're
going to get two grams of carbs out of
that four grams and you're like oh wait
a minute i didn't realize that yeah
that's right and the big food
manufacturers they know you don't know
the difference so they'll fill their
uh their fake keto foods up with lots of
soluble fiber and then on the the
nutrition information panel they get to
call that fiber not sugar
and and say oh that doesn't count
because that's fiber yeah it's it's very
insidious
it's it's very disappointing but of
course big food manufacturers they have
a duty to their board of directors to
make a profit
they have no duty to the customer to
increase their health or improve their
health right so they're they're actually
doing their job but their job is not to
help you be healthier and that's why i
talk about total carbs because you
cannot play reindeer games with total
carbs it either is a carbohydrate or it
ain't a carbohydrate and so if people
are really serious about
doing a 180 with regards to their health
you got to count total carbs and that's
very unpopular especially with you know
keto influencers who are
either manufacturing keto treats or who
are endorsing keto treats because that
that shoots their keto treat in the head
when you start counting total
carbohydrates
okay you just said play reindeer games
yeah
yeah you know how the the the reindeer
wouldn't let rudolph play any reindeer
games right oh yeah reindeer game is
basically just a [ __ ] game of
semantics or you know con you know uh
so
so yeah they'll play all the games they
can with the nutrition facts they'll
call sugar organic cane juice and
they'll say oh i've seen that yeah
exactly that's a reindeer game that's i
guess i guess that's just a personal
thing i say i thought
you said that yeah yeah but they'll do
that for a profit because their their
goal is not to make you healthier it's
to make the the bottom line healthier
okay so i also think a ketogenic diet
every bite of food you put in your mouth
needs to be nutrient dense
that's why we eat we don't eat but we
shouldn't eat for just pleasure
everybody food should be
meaningful nutrition right i think every
bite of foods you eat should be a real
whole food with one ingredient
these are all my my
definitions of a ketogenic diet uh you
might be able to use keto cookies and
cakes and pies and bars and shakes to
transition to a ketogenic diet but
ultimately if your goal is optimal
health your your diet on keto is going
to consist of a lot of fatty meat
some kale or broccoli and a few
blueberries that's that's keto if you're
if you're making keto cakes and pies
that's that's kind of keto simulacrum
that's that's it man it might help you
transition but that isn't by no means a
proper human diet
okay i agree there's a good
differentiation there uh i know i know a
lot of people who've transitioned from
the standard american diet who do have
an easier time going okay i'm not eating
pizza anymore but i'll have like keto
pizza or paleo pizza and it cuts out a
lot of the super super super harmful
ingredients
but it's not a way to so it's a way to
transition or for kids who are
really used to the standard american
diet and used to eating like sugar all
the time you can switch them onto keto
treats and they'll like hardly notice
but after a month of doing that they'll
be more inclined because the withdrawal
will like taper down they'll be more
inclined to go to whole foods
exactly and i think another thing that
the average person does not know the
average doctor doesn't know is that you
can actually train or retrain your
palate
there are so many people in the us
especially who the they're they only
know chicken chicken strip breaded
chicken strips and ketchup
and coke or pepsi that and that's
literally all the taste they can taste
they cannot taste the stuff that was me
yeah i swear that was me 100 it's very
common but people aren't aware of this
so they don't know this happens and so
they'll initially say no i don't like
meat and i'm like oh you 100 like me you
just don't know it yet because you're
used to your breaded chicken strips with
sugar filled ketchup and a coca-cola and
then you know a little debbie snack cake
at the end that's what you're used to
but you can actually retrain the human
palate and it's you know it preferably
you don't want to do that so you start a
baby out like we did beckett with beef
ribs and uh ground beef that was that
was the first foods that went in his
mouth and so he's loved meat from day
one yeah many children don't get that
opportunity they're raised on the little
rice crispy things and the little wheat
crackers
and so they never develop a true broad
human palate that can enjoy lots of
different subtlety
in the taste and the flavors and one
thing that i tell people is when you eat
a raw almond does it taste sweet to you
and if someone if they haven't been on
keto for long or they haven't they're
not
keto adapted they're like sweet no what
do you talk an almond you mean i mean if
it's like a candied almond yeah but i'm
like no no no almonds are very sweet and
when you taste that
you know that you're retraining your
palate your palate is learning oh there
are
much more subtle flavors than just
sweet sour and salty there are way
hundreds and hundreds of layers of of
the palate that you can redevelop by
slowly transitioning to eating real
human food
and when when an almond tastes sweet to
you you know you're on the proper path
you know you're moving in the right
direction
i found that for me when i switched from
standard american diet to a paleo diet
the paleo was really it was basically
keto right it was it was almost keto
it took three months so for the first
three months everything i ate was
terrible i was making stews that i would
later really appreciate but it was like
parsnips and carrots
and beef and i was just like this is
horrible like repulsive there's no
flavor here everything's kind of bitter
the meat's bland
and it was like that for three months
and then slowly carrots started to taste
sweet and then parsnips were sweet and i
was like parsnips are sweet i didn't
know that uh then i went to meat and
greens and i did that for a year
and i started to be able to
differentiate between the different
types of lettuces i was like oh no no i
want the sweet lettuce like i know that
that's the sweet lettuce i was like what
is going on it's pretty cool yeah and
the human tongue is capable of that but
most people don't know that at all they
don't know they have that it's kind of a
super power to be able to differentiate
between types of lettuce just by the
taste
but people don't realize they have that
superpower it is undiscovered
currently did your did your sense of
smell change
yeah my uh and so in in two ways my
sense of smell changed not only
did i become much more acutely aware of
smells and able to differentiate smells
but also my personal smell improved
greatly yeah my body odor has gotten so
much better on a carnivore diet and
that's something i don't think is talked
about enough but i think that speaks
directly to how the diet affects your
skin microbiome
and and your odor and so humans are
supposed to have odors but we're not
supposed to smell like a dead cat
if we don't take a bath every six hours
right
but many people notice i've got to take
two showers a day or i smell like
[ __ ]
and that the reason is is your diet is
not right you're selecting for the wrong
skin bacteria that are very uh
malodorous and that that's why you stink
my brother or my sister it's not because
just you stink it's because you're
eating a diet yeah
yeah i found i also think it's your body
trying to get rid of food so when i
tried to reintroduce soy and i i had
like no body odor totally fine on paleo
and i tried to reintroduce soy and
during the reaction when my arthritis
came back my skin broke out i like
horrifying doom my digestion was upset i
had terrible body odor and i noticed if
i got in a sauna and kind of sweated it
out then it would get a little bit
better so i think it's also your body
being like get this out of me whatever
you're eating it could absolutely be
that uh or it could be you're you re-up
regulating your skin microbiome to the
to the previous unhealthy one either
either one or a combination could
absolutely be the case
yeah
okay
so if people are interested in this
is there an easy like first do you tell
people to jump right in and just do it
and get through the withdrawal and get
through the electrolyte
up and down or is there a way to
transition in more smoothly
it depends on the person michaela is
some people are tea totalers like it
sounds like you're kind of like that
yeah i mean you're all in or i'm not
going to do it
if you're that type of person
and you're aware that you're probably
going to have some carbohydrate
withdrawal symptoms
for a few days you're probably going to
have some diarrhea for a few days
there's no danger whatsoever to just
going
from from day zero to day one to a 100
carnivore diet even a lion diet that's
in no way dangerous uh you may feel like
crap for a few days but if you're if you
understand the physiology of why you
feel like crap you understand it's worth
it to stick with it
other people
are kind of incremental improvers right
they can't they're not t totalers and so
for those people i think it's perfectly
fine
to transition slowly and to use all the
keto products as a transition tool
and then to slowly tighten up from dirty
keto or lazy keto to doing a more real
whole food one ingredient keto and then
to transition from there
to carnivore if you feel like you need
to
yeah i've noticed that this has been my
experience talking to people
specifically with serious autoimmunity
is that
some of those people have pretty bad
transition symptoms because initially i
was saying just jump in because
you're going to heal the fastest the
fastest you get on the diet so even if
the withdrawal and
and the transition symptoms are a bit
worse it's still worth it in the long
run but then there were a couple people
and you talked about potassium sodium
magnesium there were a couple of people
who didn't regulate their electrolytes
and ended up super faint with like
serious like sodium disbalances
because they didn't increase their
electrolytes first thing in the diet so
i think jumping right in if you're if
you've done your research and you're
aware that you probably need to take i i
have i was taking almost 2 000
milligrams of sodium a day
to regulate my electrolytes for quite a
while until my body got used to it like
maybe like a year and a half it took a
long time for me but i think if you can
mitigate those effects then
the sooner the better hopefully i agree
but different people have
different methods
of transition and i think that if there
if they are self-aware enough to know
which kind of person they are yeah then
they should definitely use that to their
advantage during the transition process
whether it's a teetotaler or an
incremental
because if you don't honor who you are
as a person during the transition your
risk of failure skyrockets right because
you're not you're not following the path
that you should be following and so i
think it's important for people to try
to understand which which kind of person
am i
yeah i agree
okay
dr barry you've kind of downplayed the
size of your youtube channel how many
subscribers do you have right now i
think i have 1.6 million youtube
subscribers uh
on my channel which i'm very thankful
for and very grateful for i had no idea
when when my wife nisha shamed me into
starting a youtube channel i had no
dream that it would ever become what
it's become but i'm very grateful for
that and i'm grateful that i've had the
opportunity to help so many people who
i've never met to you know and i get i
get comments all the time on the videos
it's like you've helped me lose this
much weight and i've reversed these
chronic medical conditions and i no
longer am contemplating having a knee
replacement surgery because my knee
doesn't hurt anymore that kind of stuff
and that stuff to me
that's that is payment that is that is
better than money that's better than
accolades from the american medical
association who can they can kiss my ass
by the way
uh that that's that's what keeps me
going every day is is the feedback from
people who saying who's saying you have
changed my life for the better
okay so other than
your youtube channel what's your youtube
channel called by the way uh
kendyberrymd but i think if you just
search for dr barry you'll you'll find
me
do you find it funny that your last name
is barry it is funny and you know
somebody made a a graphic of of me dr
barry
and then uh dr shawn baker
and then dr paul salad eno and they're
like it's funny that the three carnivore
doctors all have carbs in their name and
i think that's also funny but probably
that's very funny
i find that very funny okay you're also
on instagram right yeah
i'm feeling especially uh loving and
kind i'll post on instagram
when i'm feeling especially snarky i'll
post on twitter um i'm i'm currently
most proud of my uh growth on my tick
tock uh
it i i think tick tock is going to be
the next big thing yeah for sure i still
don't understand it but i'm trying
really hard to master it
i'm also i'm on all social media because
as i said in the beginning my mission is
to help as many people as i can
reclaim their best health and the only
way i'm going to do that is to reach out
to people
and currently the way you do that is
with social media
okay well
i definitely recommend anybody listening
if they're interested in these kind of
diets uh to follow dr kenbury i've been
following him for a while and he knows
what's up so thank you very much for
coming on that was a fun conversation
absolutely
thank you for good luck with the book
good luck with the book coming out too
no don't don't tell me good luck
michaela tell me to get my ass in gear i
need some do it it'll help a lot of
people and also try that you know what
try the lion diet first then do the book
and then you can see the difference just
in case like what if you're only
operating at 80 right now and you don't
even know it that's a valid point i will
i'm gonna i'm gonna put that on the
schedule
okay okay okay i'll talk to you soon
thanks a lot
[Music]
you